I wasn't sure if you know okay i will
start I need a nomination for chairman
I'll nominate give the Robin council
drain at 7am nation okay right good
evening everybody any purpose of the
tape in the absence of the chairman
councillor gerak Gibson I'll be acting
chairman this evening and welcome to the
review committee of Russia district
council treasury management task and
finish the 24th of November 2015 at
present there is myself cancer rock and
drain hair counts for George I to our
new counselor Dave sparing DNI's Murray
151 officer and Matthew pet league and
also appalled Gower's officer Aurora
District Council and I take near the
agenda that apologies for absence now no
no apologies for absence non members
attending counselor thanks Barry as
previously mentioned item three meetings
minutes of the meeting held on the
fourteenth of July 2015 are those
present happy that I signed up the true
records of the meeting yes very great
all agreed on sun house at the end of
the meeting Thank You members item four
to receive declarations of interest
young guns none on no no declarations
adding five friend to review the mid
year treasury management review for
2015-16 will consider report of the
South 151 officer before mentioned
tonie's Murray with six of views of the
review committee on the information
presented in 34 before it presented to a
for approval council on the fifteenth of
dis number 2015 any questions which
gonna start with you yes I've read
through the report to me send i have not
concerns with regards to capital as our
treasury service limited company
providing information to the council i
would like to understand how they obtain
their statistics whether they consult
the rating agencies which is moody fetch
or SP or use the statistical departments
of the government because that having
that information and and how it's been
analyzed needs to be understood at count
our council so we can go forward with
our investment in our short medium and
long term investments I i I'm not asking
you to answer that question because I
other you need to go back to capture I
think as far as I'm aware asleep your
weather capture our advisors and we
anticipate that they would actually
utilize a range of sources that we would
need them to come back and confirm to
you what those sources are that they
actually considering actually coming up
with a ratings to what we can do is that
you take that back to capita for them to
us you maybe come along and actually
give you some greater detail about I
think
it's a reef in trouble well that's not
yeah it would be possible pull that
capita can come in and give us a a
presentation of how they actually source
their information because that would be
a very clear direction in helping the
council with their future investment
yeah yes that's fine we can arrange that
yeah we have spoken about capital over
the years I haven't be under the factor
that they charge us I think 6,000 pounds
a year through their information and
I've always got the impression that so
we are happy with their information they
give us which we don't have to take of
course we don't have to take any of
their recommendations though it's advice
but they're actually providing that
advice to a large sector a large public
sector but actually what they are also
doing is giving us additional
information in terms of alternative
opportunities pneus really some of it is
based on our own risk appetite and the
scale of the investments and the need to
be able to access the funds speedily you
can either just thinking about the
safety and security of that investment
on a weekly basis we receive a credit
rating report from capita and in that
they incorporate fitch moody and
standards fours use credit overlay stops
as well to come out with a color coding
structure that's the that's the point
where I would be interested in because
from from a when you AR setting our
budgets and investments at the council
we actually etch we need to understand
how the setting knows those figures
because the marked the emerging markets
are is changing same with the
asia-pacific so the investment is going
to either cost us a lot of money if we
don't apply the money in the right of it
was a
direction that's why the turns back to
path towards but in general sorry so in
general do you still have confidence in
the advice that kappa TV yes yes yes no
concern at this stage and again that
they do offer a range of options and
something with we're happy with the
timeliness of the advice and also the
alternative energy but probably should
we ever have an appetizer diversify our
investments version because again we
have asked a question before as to where
the capita can do more for us obviously
a extra cost and i think that's been
looked into and we're happy with the
service and a level of service that they
provide any sense to other case like
they kept denying i met with the
relationship manager only a couple of
weeks ago and we we post this very
question they can offer an extensive
service i believe is yet to come back
with the full details yes yes we were
looking at alternative investment
strategies and i was given to do a
little bit more detailed work about
their different approaches to inform our
decisions going forward about what sort
of options we should be considering and
asking to do a little bit of research
about and what other local authorities
were doing such as in the property
market and center so should we be my
thoughts are outside the box at the
moment we've been using capita Treasury
service limited they had their obtaining
information from finch movie and S&P S&P
is one who largest credit rating
agencies within the UK with those rating
and credit rating agencies have got
their own departments and advisory areas
and they got access to the information
hands-on whereas captures have got a
second hands on because they are
actually buying that information
from the credit rating agency and so
those fees are being pushed onto the
council now should be we should we be
reviewing whether we do use all the
recovery phrases should we with review
whether to use capita or use one of the
credit rating agencies portfolio
management teams to help us going
forward because I'm Noah with the word
between the credit rating agency and the
government with and the latest
regulations which has being put in place
to ensure that the agencies was it I've
got the job Macomb open the W to say my
minds are my words of love but that's
right here we come back to it will come
back but what I'm saying commit to a
comparison what the credit rating
agencies can actually offer to the
capital because I think we need to
ensure that when were maximizing our
investment with this company Kevin der
the S&P the Moody's in a pinch they may
actually advise a third their own third
party company which may or may be able
to help help us who have been dealing
with the government here I mean what we
can do is do some benchmarking such I'm
not sure if you're aware that of when
our contract is to for renewal we are on
we January will be year three and a five
year contract okay
three or four five years have we got any
clauses where we can actually break it I
don't know what half of it don't care
that's very can I can I ask the question
what is the advantage in doing that as
it stands at the moment seems to me the
capture are using resources of three
companies and giving us giving an
independent perception of what these
three up to decide if we put our 18 S&P
or on the other then how are we going to
get we're sure we're just going to get
what SP or and the other credit rating
agencies believe is right we don't we
actually reduce our overall spectrum of
information by by two-thirds my missing
high restricted to one dover yeah one
yeah that I can answer that question
though David each of the credit rating
agency have got ones like all products I
and the an hour analytical teams have
got models which they work with to
actually assess how different companies
progress through financially I would
like to see capitals ensure there's
treasury services models I how they
could take that information from the
agencies and come up with an in and
figure that model needs to be defined
which needs to be presented to us
because whether that is clean forms
within the the government's tragedy for
the incredible ad agency because you
could actually take you from ocean from
three credit rating agencies and the
person is interpreting the figures may
misunderstand based of the role model
being applied okay it's been agreed that
the knees you get some benchmarking
said that we're waiting for full
information regards to capital following
your meeting commenced by haven't
finished so chairman like that to go to
divert I'm not saying that would go to
SMP and use this simply what I'm saying
is let's listen to them and get advice
from all three and they could tell us
they love other counties out there which
utilizes different models to for
investment management do you want to
come in yes okay i think that i was
going to say that the real number of
treasury management our prizes and
become benchmark a range of those i
think they benefit from capita from what
i would say that they have quite a
significant public sector are online
that brings us a lot of an advantage
significantly more i just vaguely credit
rating and they're able to tell us give
us a lot of intelligence about what
other local authorities are doing and
how they are operating in a digitally so
there may be a value add that's over and
above what we think is really i'm very
happy with that because i wasn't he in
February when it was passed oh and not
just had to get the questions were not
risen through the repair that will
definitely come back with our pre-show
co-relation think about that you want
any other questions again 3.2 it's
really how they come up with the
investor in the investment figures again
that must be i think that is that it
kept it can explain it expand on that
that just clarifies that it in terms of
the maximum investments get time to get
there and whether they add weather at
the duration whether we're looking at
short-term and long-term investments
army and it doesn't actually tell us
we've got 100 days six months and so
forth so I'm not privileged to any
previous meetings chairman with regards
to our short medium and long term
investments but it would be interesting
to
understand capita is a definition of
those three areas based off this color
coding okay okay anything else George
there's a mother of Paris 3.3 if I will
click once ignited ours yes is there any
significance in the color bandings the
[ __ ] the color Brad band exactly's
represented a number of days and the
maximum man that can be placed so if you
take the top one green if a bank or
Building Society is colored green on the
catheter creditworthiness report that
means we can put a maximum with them of
six million pounds but for no longer
than a hundred days there is no
significance in the colors no no no no
it's just how does I do not gonna be any
color know you're a consistent I'll they
said that they were very cool ok quite
biggie George you're gonna come into a
point it's just three on the trip in the
paragraph three point three what were
the changes between the revised
estimates for the credential boring over
1.7 26 million and the internal funded
some of 1.60 27 in the variation so that
is based on the actual forecaster
downturn spent for the year so i think
initially when we did the revised
estimate 1516 we forecasted might spend
four million for costs now 3.6 million
to capital projects that are being
deferred into 16 17 your completed at a
at a better value what we have been done
is actually had a look at the optimum
financing that is available capital
receipts are slightly lower than what we
don't issah paid 56 in that primary
they've been utilized in closing the
14-15 and some more of the schemes I've
required capsule receipts to be applied
to them you're close in the accounts ok
so the added totality of the capsule
receipts fund that we have available to
us now is 1.6 million my proposition is
there for them to fund my eternal
ballroom rather than external ballroom
for this year maximizing some of the
under spends that we've identified
within the financial year and then
thinking you know in terms of the
residual whether or not we then finance
that through internal volume by the cash
flow rather them to the external market
yeah directors yeah then talk about the
internal and external boring obviously
this year this this year we're looking
at the internal boring do you see at a
time when perhaps in the future we'll
have to come out for external borrowing
I think I mean I'm having those
discussions at the moment which would be
executive in terms of the approach to
fund some of these strategic investments
and also sort of trying to explain me
the importance of boring at the right
time my engine can be wattage little
advantage to bar in early while interest
rates are low and at this stage we
should be think about what is our
longer-term strategy is it more fruitful
to borrow now you know to funders and
also in about investing what we do have
more wisely select become their ensure
that we can soar beyond from so it's
something that we are considering what
is the right time to borrow that's
because I think capita originally
thought that interest rates would rise
October this year and now they've put
that back to june of next week in my
mind is a question Marcus to even when
right it will Rachel go though there's
also no relations knock it's changing
we've got chances and mirror in the
merge marks within which is in the
middle east and we've got some oil
issues which is affecting the investment
will also got changes in the Indian and
the Asia Pacific side as well the other
emerging markets which is settlement at
that South America and the east of what
are actually improving in the emerging
markets but I'm not a big concern that
capita have misjudged their forecasts of
their interest rate because you could
compare to what the rating agencies had
in place they day was bought on with the
Bank of England so that goes back to how
tech capita has interpreted the
information coming communicate track the
credit rating agencies as that will
affect away as a council use that day
they are utilize that data and that's
chairman revised I mean I think one told
me what we are seeing is you see what
you're confirming the questions that we
raised at the away oh yes yes yes about
me we do you know the this whistle
typical better big noriso yeah I imagine
and yes and I think it will be one of
the things that you'll find that Europe
will probably need to be considering of
the investment board in terms of what is
the right time to bar on the right type
of investment it may at my own view is
that actually we don't want to borrow
for what I would deem to be maintenance
and errors that you would anticipate to
be pay as you go
want to borrow for investments that will
generate some sort of return in the
future and enable us to be more self
sustainable so it's really about
considering what is the investments and
actually do we borrow now and invest it
and hold it elsewhere and it's that the
variation between the interest to be
applied on boring and again the markets
at the moment are indicating that if we
are thinking strategically there are
alternatives also to pwl be boring so
most of the time local authorities go to
public works loans board but there were
lots of things on the market that are
actually challenging those rates and
getting a better deal if loveth or just
want to work collectively but I think
even if we did look at public words
learn borders the backstop you could get
rates at your hair for three percent
between two and four percent and it's a
comparison to we do that now something
that you know really anticipating that
they will increase you know in the
future if we're doing looking at a
longer-term investment so there's all of
those trade-offs but I think what we
want to do is that when we present
propositions to the investment board it
looks at that and look sort of small
cast for that and we call it in the
business at a net present value of those
investments of similar what's the
benefit what's that cash worth now as
opposed to LA today very prudent thing
and what comes into the picture also
danusia stripper grants I mean do we
apply for grants on a regular basis
where we can and funding in different
areas you send something else to other
thing that we think about the recently
because we have the grant finder which
sort of looks and explores grants that
are available to local authorities but
what we haven't been doing is really
capitalizing
some of that we want to watch you have a
look at what are the external funding
opportunities you know in some ways you
don't want to chase grants purely for
the sake of ethical to be the right
strategic fit so the business needs but
we want to proactively be looking at
those opportunities we're looking at
ways to generate income and leveraging
income from the private sector by
match-funding receptor cells is a mixed
portfolio that we want to try to explore
but we've sort of starts to be nice to
ourselves in the in the finance work
extry more ambitious targets about
looking at those opportunities and then
bring in income inter into the authority
and to help finance these projects
because I Cherington I make a living in
Georgia armed with regards to Big
Lottery in freiburg there is a lot of
millions of pounds they're just sitting
there idle and essex are not utilizing
and as i did a bit of research the other
counties are utilizing in another form a
council perspective we need to actually
think of projects which will benefit our
business system to bring businesses into
the district and by doing so we can
action we can tap into the Big Lottery
and we've got we've got an opportunity
here to maximize our position through
those grounds here and I'll totally
agree with you that I think the council
needs to use this plan finder tool I've
used Scott good I just wondering should
we speak to the lottery people and to
give us some indication where the money
is being invested in just to give us an
idea whether the errors and the
investment could actually be mirrored in
the Rochford district area I think we
can as they have a look at their
websites i think on the website they do
to give a schedule of opportunities we
can start that as the first course and
maybe have a discussion with them a be a
potential opportunities one of the other
areas as well cuz I think you spoke
about businesses but quite often there
are funds available to community groups
that we don't turn into and then also
the need support from from the district
in terms of being able to support only
the big writing that your arm or on
actually sort of just supporting the
actual of the proposition as well and
having a local authority back in so I
think again there's going to be
recognition of what we can attract to
the district with also what we can
attract to Paris's and community groups
as well so thinking of it from the
bigger picture in terms of the greater
community at large and the overall
public / an hour wind pet does in a
positive wide male- is absolutely so
that follows that ourselves to start to
look at more studied interesting to see
that yes it will contact a good luck the
question I have on point 33 who's
getting a note that the capital receipts
have decreased from 1.8 782 1.76 or a
coupie of the reasoning for that one
particularly you have data in terms of
the other capsule is applied I think I
haven't my normal but I can provide that
Antonio please of them how the capital
with its been applied on a
project-by-project basis so you can
actually have a bit of time you
volunteer for years yes
and I think it may be worthwhile just
expanded in terms of the graphs to just
content to find a fatty the grants have
an urge to decreased it's just that we
haven't actually expended to that values
that we're assuming that will be
carrying forward into 16 17 and residual
amount sir they'll come back to the 519
which is total what we have available
okay one question George it would see
her
oh maybe jumping around sorry it's it's
dat 3.14 with regards to the
counterparties which were dropped our
investments with prepare for the benefit
of the individuals who are who are not
aware of how credit rating agencies work
we can actually write countries and we
can write in the individual companies as
well so the performance of barclays bank
and Lord paper and and the other the
other Bank as well we need I would like
to understand what he'll or the reasons
why capita have selected those three for
our investment k puke is on capital
addis now we've actually selected those
three but those three are within the cap
it's our credit rating reporters being
able to be used loads around our main
banker so that's who our current account
with okay Barclays and svenska we're
using them because they pay the best
overnight rates within our range of
where we can invest survived is
currently well they were paying point
five has dropped to point footage so
I've only left a minimum balance in
there just to keep it open right this
fence group 8.51 overnight which is
about the best but it is the best you
get out there at the moment for
overnight fro and so we've looking that
from an overnight perspective or
currently given out you really do should
we be looking out not overnight but I
had a longer period yeah the problem
we've got I mean the four and a half
million we've got in there
or had in there in this report was
written that builds up for about a month
right and then once a month we have a
day where we pay all of our precepts we
pay our salaries and we pay our business
rates back to back to counter back to
central government right that whole
amount will just go straight out on one
day so it's very hard to place for
longer than 30 days tomorrow I've
actually got Santander coming in you
know with a view to possibly opening up
a 30-day account with them that is
paying point-six percent previous to
this previous to the purchase of the
waste freighters we did have a long-term
investment one and a half million with
Lloyds paying 1.01 sin because I was
sort of interrupting Matthew I know that
there's reports about for yourself too
from three credit rating agencies with
regards to the banks would be useful for
you to actually request those reports
and so you can actually compare against
what capitals provided you you Kappa to
do provide the individual ratings
agencies plan so that the sheep we get
from cats will be an a4 piece of paper
like that it will list all the banks of
the other side yet under the sovereign
nation the list the Moody's credit
rating Fitch credit rating standard and
poor credit rating right and then
they'll apply their color applying the
credit I've relay default swaps that
they give an explanation and if they
deep whether the credit rating is
decreases or increases yes as soon as
there's a ratings watch or a
notification on a sovereign country or
an individual institution they will flag
that with a straight away and is our
department up to speed with
understanding what these writings
definition you know definition of the
writings and how it works what my team
bulldozers that email comes in we'll go
back to the original strategy that was
approved by council in January raw check
that we're still within our guy
that members have agreed if we're not
and we've got money with that
institution will pull the money straight
away and it's a song advice from boom
from capita based on the batteries do it
in accordance with what's being read by
members the rice be agreed by members
will be on the advice of catheter so
capital world advisors the members then
we'll take that information which it
will be the investment board is that
right or counsel from council curry for
the council taking on board they have
the the reasons why we going to pull out
or consider with that investment no so
in the january of each year will write
the treasury management and new strategy
which will come through this task and
finish group right to be scrutinized
okay that will then go to full council
for approval okay the the accountancy
team will then work within that strategy
guide lines that's been agreed within
the year so if during the a let's say
Barclays during the year their credit
rating dropped and we couldn't based on
the criteria laid out by capital has
gone into that report we couldn't learn
any money when we wouldn't do it we
wouldn't come back to council and say
maybe we need to lower the strategy in
some way to increase our risk we would
continue on that report that's been
agreed so that strategy which were
talking about do you think that needs to
be reviewed by the council's the plan
will be to actually rewrite that
strategy for next year yet and what's
the what's a time watching generally ffo
already started to a catheter thing
because i was privileged to when it was
passed so to point it from me and you
talked about the
national several nations yes with an oil
what happened in Iceland summit years
ago yeah obviously that is to the
forefront of many local authorities and
that's an important area is that
something that capital look into as well
and we take over and when the Iceland
situation happened capital weren't doing
their credit ratings the way they are
now in fact Iceland triggered them to
have a good look at this and redo how
they Ali doesn't provide with their
ratings it was a sorry for interrupting
where when Iceland's awesome when the
problems have a nice and you're right
there was a number of local authorities
who had investments but yeah that pretty
much triggered captors review of how
they considered how their credit ratings
will be published emotional district
council wasn't cooked up at that time
was it with the Iceland matter okay and
also in point 3.12 in page 5.5 we talked
about the council's risk appetite movies
are a every time at moment of its
capital is low and remains low so we
only answer place with very very secure
you know secure at first with very
secure rating and risk appetite has been
at around their boring etc as well and
and really that most of all funds
remaining within this sort of internet
access account so there is something
about us thinking about what is that
of working capital that we need doing a
bit more of analysis to understand what
their taste and what needs to be
accessed immediately and what can be
placed in in an account that gives a
better return forever vague and lengthy
a period as well so it's about having a
combination of the two portion flip
without expose it to miss that one
except it was a possible view of getting
more return yes at the moment the
percentage that we get is it it's good
because it's instant access but it's
very very low and actually if we are
going to be thinking about greater
investments that means that they may
have more more funds that have been held
and so that had capita advised you
whether they're the agencies are
providing any new products which we
could actually use to invest in and the
advice when we met with the relationship
manager that we advised us on on what
scent and air offering of the moment and
I'm not talking I that create rating
year these [ __ ] like cdo's or or what
about these are products which they pull
together right due to which allows you
to which the bank's purchase and put a
product so Santander will take that
product and offer a investment so the
agencies are the ones who put the
product definition together but i'm just
wondering whether capita has actually
given you any breakdown of those
products and have those products utilize
to the different banks could say that's
details and maybe some of that will be
covered in I wasn't actually intend to
the presentation is I'm just thing about
the investment how we can increase our
investment and I'm sure that we're not
going to go back to the where the
housing market issue of America
a lot of people got lost a little money
so I'm just I'm just I'm all thinking
out of the box but how capital is
providing us information and and how
up-to-date it is and whether we're with
the captor are doing what they're
supposed to be doing that's all okay
thank you George anything else
there's one there's a question the area
of mentioning 3.15 that the target rate
is between five percent I think this may
have been answered in there is a
forecast investment return of 40,000
pounds around which is around 7,000
lower than the original anticipated and
what percentage rate would be achieved
if we did to get 50,000 return it's just
the question which was passed through to
the yeah well let me put a little bit of
extra shot the original budget set in
january of this year for investment
income was 47,000 at that time it was
anticipated that we would have a
one-year investment with Lloyds through
the whole of this year when it came to
purchasing the waist vehicles the
decision was made to pull that
investment to fund part of the waste
vehicles lat investment was a for a
million and a half pounds with Lloyds
pain 1.01 percent because that was
pulled all of our cash now as you've
seen earlier is overnight at point five
point five one percent so that's why the
investment for cost is lower for the end
of the year so the average inter of
interest rate had we had the Lloyds
investment we were in somewhere about
point A or point nine on sin but because
it's now a point five it's scary lalo
in 22.3 13 investments place for the
first about 15 to 30 sep tember 15 were
18.8 this can you give us some more
information regards to the investments I
can top that I think when eight million
16 and a half a million was invested
with handles banking and two and a half
2.3 million with Barclays all for
varying degrees of duration but none
longest I've gotten there was 69 days
which one was I thought that were then
that was for one and a half million
pounds we didn't info and should we
invested two million on a couple of
occasions to three occasions generally
during an average month where we can we
can invest a million our half or more
around a million our half for around 30
to 40 days the rest of it it's all done
for Arab the working cattle side okay
thank you do you have children yeah I'm
just thinking I'm thinking about the
future with the business right on
thinking where are we with business
rights and whether because I don't know
what didn't like the story is because
that's going to be one area which is in
respective so the council we can keep
more of the business which is that's
right question it's a business rates
growth and yes where we are definitely
in the details hope it will hear a
little bit more tomorrow about the
changes being proposed and
conference is ending with you it was
cool but its present the expectation is
that that local authorities will be able
to retain one hundred percent growth in
business rates but in doing that there
will be increased increased
responsibilities that come with us so we
need some clarity in terms of what that
is and there's also proposal that more
of the revenue support grants will be
rolled into the same figure so presence
we get to grant funding and we get the
business right and the view is that if
we get more of the race then we'll be
actually reduced in the grants and
coming to that hardcore ya wanna Jana so
Tony Chen as i said the will undoubtedly
be some growth activity you want and
some of that will be retained by
ourselves locally and really reality
will be how does that sort of compare
with more certainly min sort of appeals
sector as well and you know it enclosure
so well it will it will have to balance
out there's a potential opportunity but
we're not sure what the risk I was
welded transfer I might we might not
known until hopefully we'll get some
greater granularity tomorrow both we
won't show exactly how much detail will
come through but we're hoping that the
Chancellor will spell out the increased
responsibility that comes with them I
love the view that there could be
something around skills cookie ball all
got social care again as well the
overview is that the Chancellor will
also be trying to smooth the impact on
on local authorities that don't have the
opportunity to generate growth generate
that level of sort of smooth than or
equals a shin is done centrally if the
growth is actually all given out my
authority is going to be an element of
that prior to prior to the growth so to
do
I'm thinking further down like the the
presets which we give it to our parishes
and all that because that day an old
would be affected and so depth of the w
revised its we're not anticipating that
any changes are made until we actually
get some great achren hours he about and
responsibilities that come with that and
how much of that will be truly retained
at a district level as opposed to it
account to level as well because the
business rates this generation are
apportioned across the number of parties
and we find out tomorrow I does a little
bit more detail tomorrow what generally
happens in the comprehensive spending
review is that the focus is that
government department level right from
that we generally trying so when
actually that you know if they're going
to be cutting this department by eggs
then what do we think that would mean at
a local level and we try and sort of
extrapolate some of the information to
get a high-level indication of what we
think that will mean for for ourselves
we were absolutely now what it means
until December when we have the
financial settlement says now this is
the grant that we're going to be giving
watch for District Council but what we
will be trying to do tomorrow is
reviewing the details of the
comprehensive spending review
translating that sort of to be able to
provide you with an all the day
statement of what we think these are
agreeing I'm it'll be members are oh yes
fantastic i'll just a high level in
terms of this is the on very thin our
translation of the comprehensive
spending review the futures firm and
then some greater granularity when we
start to unpick some of the details i
will say you know we'll be reading
through all the treasury statements etc
as well as listen to them listening to
the announcement and trying to
some sense of it you know it's a high
level view for tomorrow the details in
the fine print is the excitation you
mentioned George Abela preset for the
tears on parachutes but I don't think
they're actually affected by my business
variable goodbye rsg yeah yeah the local
council tax support will have an impact
on those yeah so yeah yeah now I will be
interesting though sort of detail yes to
she is a possible opportunity though for
I think the business rates of growth and
could be an opportunity see it will
depend on the level of activity in this
area because I think we've obviously
seen some downsides as well with some
business closures and my view is
actually with the economic cycle Tony
growth picking up wouldn't expect to see
that there's a recovery and we should
start to see some of the benefits of
that again so is it just about the scale
but will confirm what we need to just be
mindful of is that that the increased
responsibility or any new burdens is
appropriately funded and that we're
aware of the the hidden elements and can
actually you know make representation to
government if we feel that it's not it
can't be contained I will go to assume
that out my way up tension favorite
areas would be in building yes our data
says the giver yes that will be the
bigger because acetate and how we
maximize up ebonies the way board and of
course over to spin off from the airport
as well yeah that must be used on
yourself in yes and its benefits
yep sure is coming in tourist market the
the question is do we we reinstate the
fair of your from south ends Monday I
don't know no this is what I think we've
got a lot of opportunity for expansion
but it's how we're going to do it yeah
and end up with what tools don't just on
that point George obviously there is
this devolution thing moving around as
well as I'm down but I know what the
ramifications of that will be in you
know either anticipate that if the
devolution proposition and reaches
fruition that should bring it with it
additional benefits particular round
business growth business enterprises and
the benefit of having a combined
authorities that will be shared across
the greater Essex and so all authorities
would benefit from growth within greater
estates so we wouldn't necessarily lines
on that growth being generated here in
rochford in order to deter an increase
from the business rate of growth so
that's the way in which the model words
is then actually it's a greater Essex
approach adopted sawal growth we've
benefited all maybe not as to the same
proportion as those that are directly
impacted by the growth but we have an
equalization model which means that
every authority takes that a purple
I think you'd like to anything welp I
think you think we've answered I had one
more question as regards to the the
weight vehicles we're still purchasing
those jutsu preciouses waste we have
never purchased me oh and there was an
overdraft facility of two million pounds
put in place a cost of 5,000 pounds
correct is that still there and I that
is closed in October good okay and we
only utilized it on three days three
captions prevention before the capital
plans and can you give us a list of the
capital compli the plans you've got the
capital firm for the future a severe
follow me that may be explaining and the
strategy in the approach you'll probably
see it in the in the quarter to
financial report well what I've actually
done essentially had a look at the
entire capital program on the financing
of the capital program and were able to
finance this year in its entirety based
on utilizing the capital recedes and the
only funny finance elements that we've
noted in this report what we've actually
try to also identify is a revenue
element to be able to fund things that
we consider as being maintenance and
thinking more strategical watching a
more strategic overview of the investor
save investor generate type projects to
come forward so the view is that we
actually rethink the whole capital
strategy look at the disco
that we currently have in the pipeline
make a decision in terms of which of
those should continue which others are
essential in terms of things like
whether that's being provisional car
park maintenance fund those from a
revenue source so there's a revenue
contribution to capital because they are
the sort of page you go type screen and
then for the investment board to decide
on the schemes or the pipeline you have
capital projects that then should form
the residual capital program and capital
strategies to that sort of
recommendation that's going to be coming
through into the the quarter to
financial report and that's the work
that's currently underway and by
officers to actually review the program
and then decide on which schemes are
essential schemes so that was at work
tool too it's really more the asset
management where he'll open in
supporting all tomorrow's but at least
the offices that are driving the project
and they're discussing those projects
without portfolio holders to make
decisions on which of the essential
projects and which project should come
back for a review and consideration by
the investment board so we've coming up
with two schedules these ones that we
recommend to go forward and these the
ones that we will walk yourselves to
consider in terms of and the
bridger-teton why you've recommended and
boy you're not recommending our other
projects yes so I think it will be
detailed in terms of those that we we
consider to be essential and those are
essential
what I mean an example would be and it's
not high maintenance but the provision
of bins for the you know for the actual
waste collection use that may be
something that we need to do on an
ongoing basis but I've use it as an
ongoing recurrence pained it's something
that we need to be able to ensure that
we have sufficient funds program to
finance that but it is something that
we'd want to borrow to be able to
provide in my future so we're sort of
separating the two and having a clear
distinction in the program which those
schemes that are essential in terms of
running the operation run to the
business or essentially pers that could
be something like car park maintenance
and then actually have a look at the
other schemes and think about actually
are these the right type of schemes that
we want to invest in and should we be
progressing those and then they'll be
decision for for the board okay thank
you anything else rules I think this has
already been taken care of is the I 10.8
million up you've really done this year
headed up by under the other questions
and the recommendation is to
the 30 mainland task and finish resolves
to recommend the contents of the Sonia
report for council is that a group from
here also to identify and if you shoot
any issues on this topic for further
consideration discussion by the group it
was there were some better to come out /
all yep and I think man yes therefore we
made notes and your comeback special we
were live saint of you talk again thank
you in your engine but effective them
for the purposes of the tape I would
like to say that the emergency
declaration announces was taken to read
prior to the meeting opening and they
are closed a meeting at eight 20